exciting times of course to see the
reveal here of uh some high level
overwatch 2
objective where you gamepl the robot
here uh he'll push the barricades
depending on who controls uh the
objective back and forth uh what's
really great about this is obviously
that there's a you know not many
scenarios you can tie it's also one of
the game modes uh that you kind of find
where there's not uh there's not really
kind of an offense and defense like a
hard offense or defense on either side
uh you're looking at you know just
playing just a kind of completely uh
variable map where sometimes you're on
deep end sometimes you're on offense a
lot of just flow to it
absolutely uh and look and space said
there's a lot of fighting he felt like
there was a ton of skirmishes going on a
lot of back and forth stuff here it's
got to be five versus five of course uh
and we already get to see some of these
locks to start things off we're gonna
see bastian straight off the bat which
is great also sombra so both these two
new look heroes with their reworks are
going to be coming out the gates well
also a reminder that there's some of the
other changes that were in the pvp
stream that are in here as well right
reinhardt when he charges can kind of
control and maneuver himself he's got
that power steering bike his face coming
out of the spot right i know being able
to get right towards that choke in the
uh double fire strike so some changes
there with reinhardt as we get to the
mix so this is a pretty deadly area of
the map right a large long corridor it's
something we usually like don't really
have like a lot in overwatch one these
like massive long drawn out sight lines
there it is bastian on the move unreal
we see the biotic grenade thrown in
there by shoe
but i mean the fact that you can move
around and have that gatling gun
potential now also the primary fire
okay it is a bit different yeah that's
right yeah it's it's uh it's really good
in like long range scenarios we see here
from i know kevster's pov sombra right
uh used in much more of like an
offensive way uh space gets hacked but
you see how fast the abilities come back
online in a nice fin there to take out
closer okay space is dirty look at the
maneuverability that he has for such a
short range charge he can still connect
so this means that team one are on the
road they're pushing here and uh
obviously
two i think two is our name for for the
robot here yeah so you can see uh the
top of the screen right i know the blue
team is in the lead right now pushing
that robot when the red team gets
control of it it'll kind of move faster
back towards the middle it's really tied
to the team's barricade more than
anything is uh bird ring here on the
junkrat on the flank we see a lot of
people getting hacked by this sombra
right there but it's for a brief time
that their abilities are unavailable we
saw this one in the preview i think yeah
space is getting a little bit uh a
little bit nutty with it getting right
into the face there of mag and even as
an earth shadow to spend here now these
ultimates don't come as easy right
you're not getting no nearly as much old
charge from from damaging tanks well yes
and i also think one thing you do
realize right away is how much more
offensive the tanks are right uh where
space is able to get right up uh in that
area and see mag there it's interrupted
and he actually tries to go for a
shatter but it's going to be an emp from
decay on the other side bird ring on the
genji by the way nasty stuff assassins
already picked off while mag sleeps it
off and that's the emp coming out but
vertebrae still has obviously the use of
the dash so soon after the emp hits
trying to deal with the aggression from
moth here in valkyrie yeah you kind of
think of emp now right as like a a large
one-second interrupt and then it's
really about sombra getting the damage
benefit after that
damage as well right and trying to
actually finish players off uh see
that's a nice hack here
uh on to moth as uh he'll end up falling
so assassin does have this uh bastional
we'll see if uh he's able to get a good
use of it uh as on the other side you
also see it's gonna be mag with a
shatter you see in between the
barricades t the barricade excuse me two
moves quite quickly so yeah it didn't
take long after winning the fight for
team two to be back in control of the
objective and now they're starting to
move their barricade up just look at
this
my controller yeah he's not ready the
hydraulics are just too insane mag finds
the shadow knocks space on down looks
for assassin who's sleeping and bird
rings gonna go for the blade here that's
one that's two and almost getting on
fifty percent of it forty percent of an
entire team with one blade is pretty
nice yeah and i think you can see just
how you know uh obviously overwatch a
very fast-paced game but in 5v5 just the
aggression and fast pace you can play at
and i think it's a great point right
they were used to like two kills with
the dragonblade fight being for a very
long time here's the national
side and the cruise missile
three spots down here you see mack takes
a decent amount of that splash damage
jeff was talking about it earlier but
able to get healed up pretty quick we
have a zaga here though for space bear
in mind zaya has two bubbles she can
bubble herself twice or a teammate twice
and that shield of max just disappears
emp gets thrown in there moth is awfully
low as skewed goes for that little sleep
dart
see assassin is super low and skewed
showing us a little bit of that anna
very nice as he's able to keep everybody
charged up and you see one of the ticks
on the top of the screen as uh the red
team is approaching it uh that's gonna
be a bit of a checkpoint there uh for
push so that'll give them a little bit
of a forward spawn
location yeah it would be kind of crazy
if they had to spawn all the way in the
back you know to try and get the the
objective uh at this point uh also just
to remind people this is a different
version of zarya zarya has the two
bubbles on a shared cooldown the reaper
guy goes in
the sound of the hellfire shotguns as
well it rattles right especially in that
underpass it's something that space
talked about right i know graphically
obviously you know the new hero looks
for a lot of the different heroes uh in
this build but then also just the the
weapon sounds it's one of the things
where uh i think speaking to some of the
players who have had some hands on
they're like man the damage just feels
so strong and i think it's because the
there's the the
sounds of the guns and everything just
feels so much more like violent right it
feels really like more real i think than
kind of like overwatch i noticed the
sound playing when one of your teammates
has been eliminated like you'll be
hearing knockout elimination or lockout
excuse me look at the emp look at the
percent health damage on bag he gets
blown to smithereens by kevs to after
with the damage increase yeah and it
just makes sombra like an offensive
powerhouse right you kind of look at
players who play sombra now uh really
just trying to play more of a
team-oriented game and now it is just
way more of kind of almost like playing
a little bit of a tracer version so the
blue team gonna get up get towards this
barrier you can see now they take the
lead at the top of the screen they are
in charge that yellow line represents
the enemy team's sort of furthest
progress so they can tell when they've
sort of gotten ahead
enemy forward spawn change this so with
that checkpoint now that changes
obviously uh where the leading team come
from
yeah this is scary that's one that's two
god the time to kill feels lower i mean
birding is attacking non-tanks to be
fair but space also was the first to
fall back
had the rally but he didn't have it for
much longer as nanoblade regardless so
you know 6v6 3v3 5v5 whatever you want
to play is still
so impactful is uh space now see if he
can get charged up on this zarya you're
gonna have like a death blossom plus
grab combination
all right cwa is pretty much sat in the
middle of the map for the time being but
team one lead with under two minutes now
left there's the grab
pretty nice clean up
easier for spikes to get a ton of charge
individually now he can be
self-sustaining and you can hear the bee
man with the nano it just sounds so
filthy
that'll be a team wipe here uh for the
blue team as they are still in the lead
just trying to get the barricade even
further right forward their progress
make it even harder for the red team to
come back is some more changes here uh
for the red team as i'm sure a lot of
these players experimented throughout
this as birdering now over the reaper
mag on the diva so i know a lot of uh no
players just even of the tank roll in
general are a little bit kind of uh
worried they think about diva in solo
play but she's so good as like a duelist
like 1v1 that she's able to really be
pretty pretty strong we definitely
already knew that right that was
something that she showcased you know in
overwatch for quite some time bird ring
i mean this is a much more familiar pick
for him
nasty stuff his space there gets kind of
blown up again it was mentioned i think
space said that tanks feel like sort of
bigger dps's they also fall just as
quickly in some cases now well i i think
you can also see how like speed and just
uh verticality is going to end up
playing right where you know mag is able
to get in a position make a play but
then also use the defense matrix that is
a nice sleeper he's dead oh he's dead
that is a nice sleep from skewed i'm
sure uh i'm sure he'll want that one for
the highlight reel is it looks like the
blue team actually going to try and rap
through the middle of the map so that's
one thing with the objective being
really like a neutral objective is
there's a lot of areas to play in the
middle of the map that you can just you
don't have to circumvent to go play for
a you know static objective like a
control or something like that there's
so many different routes you can take
because obviously the robot will take
long to get back to the barricade you
can take numerous fights in different
areas there's a sense where you don't
necessarily always want to fight around
where two is right i think so so these
fights are being taken uh externally to
where the robot is so we're also getting
very close to overtime seven seconds on
the left uh left over time will trigger
because the red team is behind right now
with the blue team in the lead they'll
have an opportunity as long as they
control this to keep moving the robot
forward right and so they're on the
score you can actually see where team
two need to get to to win the round you
can't draw this really at all right
unless two and never move so i guess
that is one situation would be difficult
and you jinx us
emp for three
two o just hanging out just hanging off
the barricade
death blossom here by bird we can try
and clear some space team two are moving
for the time being and they're using
that to break line of sight right using
twi and the barricade to avoid the
damage but damn team one got back
awfully quick yeah the barricade gives
you a little bit of a space there to be
able to move up almost a little bit like
cover to get in position and it's gonna
be the blue team wiping the red team off
of robot not pushing the barricade
anymore so that'll end up with a blue
team winning which uh that's really
exciting to see like the first kind of
competitive showing of push because i
think i know right it was uh you know
blizzcon two years ago or i mean the
time just blends in right now where we
saw it played on toronto uh and that was
really just kind of like a lot of play
tests with you know the general public
and whatnot to see the pros play it in
like a competitive environment it's
really interesting uh i also think you
can kind of see uh from some of that
gameplay right it's like ultimates are a
little bit harder to gain uh in terms of
like right you know tanks taking you
know one less tank and there are
definitely less of them right yeah also
tanks generating less ultimates but that
also allows you to switch
pretty frequently right you can play
different things at different times and
you know really make an impact by
switching heroes at the right time i was
really impressed by some of these fights
being taken away from the objective it
seems like you'd fight on the objective
or just external to it because the maps
feel so much bigger right there's so
many different routes you can take we
could gush about this for quite a while
we've got to get on the show
exactly i do want to hear obviously how
the desk has to react to this because
obviously we've got some ex pros there a
lot of excitement around overwatch to
push so shall we in the crew take it
away